have you seen these hippos in Colombia
hippos don't naturally live in Colombia
but in the 1980s the infamous drug lord
Pablo Escobar imported four hippos from
Africa for his private zoo I visited
these guys a few years ago for an
episode of ox borders and they're cute
but very dangerous they've now
proliferated and there's 165 of them and
it's becoming a massive problem last
year A man was attacked by one of these
hippos and the government finally is
deciding that they have to take real
action they were super hesitant to just
shoot these hippos for obvious reason
but now they have decided they have to
to at least a few of them they also are
trying to sterilize them which seems
like a good idea but I talked to the guy
who actually does this and he's like
it's way harder than you think to
sterilize a 4,000lb mammal but they got
to do something because if they don't
estimates say that there's going to be
over a thousand of these hippos roaming
around Columbia by 2035 I've been
following this story for years and I'm
going to keep following it because it's
quite interesting to me if you want to
better understand current events and
international news follow along for more